that betrayal of megyn kelly was insane
I mean it was it was mind-blowing that
prefer right oh my god megyn kelly here
did you I mean I know Megan Kelly Megan
let me hear your voice let me hear you
do when you prepare for that I just
figure it's like what you don't you'd
have to watch like thousands of hours of
megyn kelly just to get it down right
the challenge was her was her voice more
than anything because yeah we're kind of
like fair blonde
we've very different shaped faces but
you can even put that aside but the
sound her sound was just you know that
was like the biggest thing for me called
the paranoid man who decides your celery
a pervert and do that on a [ __ ]
anonymous hotline he controls we'd
always have her on in my car and I would
drive around and I would just talk over
her like well she was because she talks
very fast so she would I would just hear
her talk and I would just talk with her
just [ __ ] Megan and I would just talk
in my car all the time is there a point
where you start to lose confidence and
go I can't pull this off because it this
is playing a person that everybody knows
and or do you know right away I'll be
able to figure this out you know you're
not making a documentary so you know
it's not gonna be exact so you're just
always kind of in the back of your mind
thinking well how far away from exact
are we gonna be that's really I guess
how I gauge it every single day and
Sundays are a lot harder than other days
some days you just you just can't find
it and it's demoralizing but I worked
with this incredible voice coach on that
show and I had a really really bad day
where I could not she came over to my
house and I could not I just could not
find the sound and the depths and the
cadence I couldn't find anything and she
she left and she left this note on my
table and it says I don't know if you'll
be able to read it says your inner outer
megyn kelly is still there just around
the [ __ ] corner
and you frame it I have it this you run
it on a piece of paper but it shouldn't
like that that just like you know gets
you through the day
you